pourquoi le petit prince de lui n'était
pas là
dans le petit prince Louis n'était pas
là pourquoi il était pas là alors c'est
qui je suis là alors déjà je suis là
c'est un des enfants de Kate et William
c'est le dernier fils le dernier c'est
le petit Louis de Galles il faut savoir
qu'en Angleterre c'est une star bien sûr
il a 4 ans et lui il arrête pas de faire
des cacas c'est ça hein il fait plein de
caca
fait plein de caca
regardez parce que en fait il a un
caractère très fort on a pu le voir dans
plusieurs cérémonies regardez ce gosse
et voilà et en fait ils ont mis de côté
hein ils l'ont laissé à la maison
exactement regardez je vous montre une
vidéo
ça passait pas
[Musique]
et donc lui ils l'ont dit tu viens pas
il est resté à la maison avec Steiner
sans Maria borallo et son petit chien et
alors il s'est vraiment une star je vous
le disais en Angleterre depuis le vague
toutes ces images là ils adorent le
poisson je l'adore ouais et alors il
faut savoir que deux choses il se plaint
auprès de sa maman donc il lui a dit il
était triste et lui a dit bah donc on ne
pourra plus aller à Balmoral alors que
elle le rassure elle dit
la reine masqué
[Rires]
et puis il faut quand même reconnaître
on aime on n'aime pas Cyril mais il faut
quand même reconnaître que les Anglais
ils ont quand même le chic et de France
pour organiser c'est un peu Hollywood
c'est dans le fond noir en France quel
côté Hollywood Jack quand on sent ses
images il faut savoir qu'il Élisabeth II
elle avait voulu tout ce qui s'est passé
et depuis 1760 on avait plus assisté à
l'enterrement d'un ancien souverain sous
les voûtes ministère
le deuxième question qui n'a pas été
invité à la cérémonie elle m'a parlé
alors on m'a parlé de six pays qui n'ont
pas été invités absolument pas avec la
Russie n'a pas été absolument la
Biélorussie ouais la Birmanie oui
l'Afghanistan oui la Corée du Nord non
ils y étaient là Corée du Nord bah
pardon le Venezuela
et la Syrie oui absolument ils n'ont pas
été invité non c'est ce qu'on m'a dit
Corée du Nord Iran et nicaraguay a eu
longtemps pour parler mais ils ont pour
finir été quand même invité Parly James
caverny c'est le nouveau ministre des
Affaires étrangère oui c'est le
oui c'est celui qui a vraiment du régler
tous ces jeunes pour parler que les
différents ministères on rappelle que le
monde entier compte 185 pays et puisque
6 n'y était pas bah vous l'avez donc 189
qui était représenté
au monde c'est-à-dire que c'est pas la
première fois qu'autant de pays sont
invités dans le cas de JFK ça a été le
cas par exemple mais tous n'avait pas
répondu présent ici ils ont tellement
répondu présent qu'on leur ramène voilà
on est désolé vous devez limiter vous
avez deux places par pays
deux places par pays c'est pas la
couronne qui a qui a fait la liste c'est
le gouvernement c'est-à-dire c'est un
acte politique
je connais son frère
il y en a un autre qui rêvait d'être là
mais t'as pas reçu ton carton
d'invitation c'est Donald Trump
ah ouais mais pourquoi il voulait quoi
parce que c'est un grossier personnel
non c'est vrai oui aucune éducation
qu'est-ce qu'il a fait bah il a osé
venir avec son hélicoptère en 2018
sur le sur le gazon de Buckingham Palace
il a fait des troupes les deux étaient
épouvantaires et elle le redoutait elle
redoutait ses opinions politiques à tel
point que elle s'était parée de la
fameuse parure de rubis et alors elle a
ostensiblement devant les photographes
elle caresser sa parure alors pourquoi
et en réalité parce que le rubis et ben
c'est une il a un pouvoir là c'est ça il
repousse les forces du mal je sais c'est
comme on veut
[ __ ]
et il y avait aucun autre président
américain avait Joe Biden c'est tout oui
absolument et Joe Biden il avait une lui
il était tous dans un bus et lui il
était dans une limousine blindée
c'est un escadia qui pèse plus de 2
tonnes et alors comme tous les pays
étaient représentants on avait des pays
dont on n'a jamais entendu parler ou
très peu Djibouti par exemple
[Musique]
la Dominique par exemple
Dominique la République Dominicaine
[Rires]
une principauté c'était en dehors en
dehors
[Applaudissements]
il est coprace d'Andorre Emmanuel
non vous divertissez toute la famille
alors la Tunisie pour le coup était
représente
quelque chose peut-être qui est souligné
c'est que les caméras de la BBC à aucun
moment elles n'ont zoomé sur les têtes
couronnées qui étaient quand même
présente au nombre de 50 y avait
Charlène Albert de Monaco il y avait
toutes les têtes couronnées d'Europe
étaient présentes pourquoi parce que
l'Angleterre elle a rien à faire quoi
il y a qu'une couronne voilà c'est fou
ça
dans la presse cette année qu'on a parlé
le plus de Joe Biden et de Emmanuel
Macron les deux qui ont déjà vedette
Macron c'est parce que quoi ici il est
arrivé dans les baskets et lunettes donc
déjà c'est un peu étonné on va dire et
puis voilà les il y a une relation qui
est particulièrement entre les deux
pétales
appeler on l'a dit il y a une embrouille
en direct ça monte elle lui a dit ouais
c'est quoi il m'a mal parlé il a dit je
vais le défoncer écoute
là-bas il y a une balayette qui allait
partir faire
on dirait qu'il va balayer un gars c'est
toi qui a mal à Brigitte là
c'était pas pour se recueillir pour se
recueillir ils se sont changés
histoire du bus sont dit qu'Emmanuel
Macron
il a pris le bus il a pris le bus il a
pris le bus troisième chose Harry a-t-il
été interdit de saluer le cercueil de la
reine alors on va rappeler qu'il arrive
c'est pas une marque de pain de mie
c'est grave
le fils de Charles le fils de Charles
fils d'Elisabeth II chat Harry est marié
avec
Renaud maintenant tu dois dire Renault
Mégane
[Applaudissements]
et donc pourquoi ils l'ont dit non alors
pourquoi ils l'ont dit non parce que bah
il a été destitué de son titre de son
prédicat d'Altesse royale suite au fait
qu'il a quitté la famille royale
ici depuis 2020 il n'est plus il a pu
garder son titre de courtoisie et celui
de duc de ce sexe mais officiellement il
ne peut plus représenter la couronne et
il faut savoir que dans le protocole et
bien pour saluer vraiment la dépouille
dans souverain seuls sont autorisés à le
faire les personnes qui portent
attention un slip un uniforme
militaire et comme il n'a pas pu revêtir
cette uniformes militaire il n'a pas pu
officiellement saluer
des histoires de pédophilie mais ce qui
est tout à fait incroyable dans cette
histoire et en gros c'est que ce sont
les deux seuls à s'être battu un jour
sur le front Andrew il a participé à la
guerre des Malouines quand même Harry
ici il était en Afghanistan alors que
tous les autres tous ceux qui vraiment
ils n'ont jamais vraiment
du tout en train de critiquer les
Windsor mais je n'oserai mais je dis
juste que l'histoire elle s'amuse quand
la veille pour la pour veiller la reine
il a eu le droit de le porter la lune la
veillée des Petits Princes on a baptisé
ça la veillé des petites samedi et
exceptionnellement avec qui c'est Noël
ce gâteau de Noël que tu me fais il a
cuit s'exprimer et s'exprimer je peux
m'exprimer il arrive en effet ça arrive
exceptionnellement le samedi il a obtenu
de la part du roi l'autorisation en
effet de se recueillir sur les dépôts de
la feuille
en costume militaire mais si je peux
ajouter une toute petite
et vous savez même le roi n'était pas au
courant de cela il a découvert que les
armes d'Elisabeth 2 donc le er Elizabeth
wedjina avait été découvert quoi
il s'appelle Elisabeth la reine morte ça
s'appelle
intéressant ça pourquoi et Isabelle
Rennes
et maintenant c'est Charles ah
maintenant c'est Charles original
les tableaux anglais sont pas toujours
élégants parce qu'à propos du prince
Harry on rappelle une ressemblance avec
James Hewitt bien sûr
de la princesse
[Rires]
pourquoi démarre tracter le cercueil
très belle 140
[Rires]
de 1901 et les obsèques de la reine
Victoria que c'était des chevaux
la reine Victoria je fais des chevaux
qui tractait la dépouille mortuaire et
les chevaux se sont cabrer ils se sont
excités
non qui pèse quand même deux tonnes et
demi ce sont les marins de la Royal
negal à l'époque avait tracté la
dépouille et depuis bah c'est devenu un
peu pour les remercier leur rapanage ça
leur est réservé ils étaient 142
dispatché en deux groupes le groupe à
l'avant tractait et le groupe à
l'arrière avait pour mission de retenir
et de freiner
c'est toujours la même et la corde est
d'origine depuis 1901 absolument c'est
beau ça c'est plein de petites anecdotes
le temps et là on le voit très bien on
ressort cette affût de canon qui n'avait
plus été sorti depuis 1965 autre
obsèques nationales pour le décès de
Winston Churchill Winston Churchill
il y a un 5e secret sur la cérémonie
hier
cérémonie
la reine Elizabeth
London Bridge
c'était le nom de code militaire je
croyais qu'elle avait donné à cette
opération c'est une opération militaire
à Cyril organisé les obsèques en jour
c'est vrai funérailles c'est l'opération
militaire
le monde a pris le monde avait donné
plus c'est vrai il était triste Emmanuel
Macron ben il les rapports avec la
France sont très bonsoir
on rappelle qu'elle parlait en français
et lorsqu'elle se disputait avec
Philippe pour ne pas que les domestiques
comprennent quoi en français ils parlent
en France
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
avec tous les présidents je sais il a
fait une table de ping-pong
c'est quoi le cadeau
fabuleux de mon cours en effet à cheval
de la gare de républicaine et les
mauvaises langues disent que ma pauvre
cheval parce que depuis qu'il est passé
dans les écuries royales il bosse
le cadeau d'Emmanuel le fameux chevaux
avec chacun des présidents qu'elle avait
rencontré ah ça c'était le cadeau de la
réception de dimanche donc
la réception
du siècle c'était la réception du siècle
dimanche il y avait en effet mille
invités qui étaient sans faire quoi
comme cadeau les chefs d'État alors
Emmanuel Macron un cheval non non un
album photo le cheval c'était pour le
jubilé
manuel n'est pas arrivé avec un cheval
dimanche en disant tenez voici le cadeau
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
il a acheté quoi un album photo
là c'est une visite d'État officielle
elle a accordé à la France
de Gaulle
elle est venue cinq fois en France je
crois il a fait tous les cas il a fait
tous les et qui sont fait les autres
ce que on veut faire les autres chefs
d'État là je vous avoue
quoi donc depuis 20 ans Auriol le
premier président de la façon original
est le premier ministre est-ce que vous
vous imaginez et lorsqu'elle n'est pas
encore reine elle rencontre le bras un
certain LeBron James
le prof de Daniel c'était parfait
quoi Albert Lebrun mais oui tu sais même
pas toi Albert Lebrun mais c'est pas une
couleur je crois alors
dernière révélation
pour la cérémonie les joyaux de la
couronne étaient disposés sur le cercle
de la reine
elle sera pas enterrée avec puisqu'ils
seront remis au nouveau roi Charles fuit
lors de son couronnement c'est quand le
couronnement de Charles le fruit
alors on ne connaît pas encore là la
date vraiment du couronnement par contre
ce que l'on sait déjà ce qu'il veut une
cérémonie simplifier on rappelle que le
couronnement d'Elisabeth dans 53 c'était
trois heures de cellules je peux
peut-être le voir David Guetta et on
avait invité 8000 à 8000 personnes lui
dit déjà qu'il veut quelque chose de
simplifié et elle porte également en
étant monarchie un nom de code cette
cérémonie du couronnement ce sera le
Golden orbe pourquoi parce que l'orbe
vous savez c'est le globe que l'on va
voir d'ailleurs tout à l'heure et qui
symbolise vraiment le fait que on dirait
voilà
elle est bien la photo
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'émeraude ça coûte combien
ça n'a pas de prix ça fait partie des
joyaux de la coureur vous avez devant ce
que je vous appelle le globe donc l'Orb
en quelque sorte alors j'ai la
soumission pourquoi est-ce qu'il est
rond parce que c'est la terre qui est
soumise à la loi du Christ c'est pour ça
vous voyez qu'il y a une petite croix
juste au-dessus ah d'accord le jour du
couronnement il est remis dans la main
gauche du souffre ça c'est le roi
absolument dans sa main droite
anecdote drôle il est mieux en crypté
c'est que en 1936 pour les obsèques de
George V et de là il faut savoir que la
croix de maille qui est sur la couronne
elle est tombée lors des obsèques de
George sac oui alors que les marins
c'est le corps là une fameuse une pierre
est tombée et des spécialistes ont dit
vous allez voir ça va porter malheur non
et en effet on est 11 mois qui ont suivi
donc descente 1936 le nouveau roi il
abdique pour épouser
qui ne s'est jamais vu en Milan
d'histoire et on dit que et bien le roi
Charles III lorsqu'il a appris le dessin
animé quand il a été face au corps tout
de suite il a dit il faut impérativement
que l'on fasse réviser l'intégralité des
joyaux c'est trois joyaux qui vont être
posés sur les cercueils tout de suite
Marc Apple bye ça marque applebaï c'est
la couronne c'est pas le fameux départ
de la famille dandy on dit bague
rappelle comme une pomme appelle bail et
il faut savoir que avec le souffrant et
l'archevêque de Canterbury qui est la
plus haute autoritaire religieuse il est
le seul à pouvoir toucher les trois
joyaux que vous voyez donc il a été
appelé expressément et on l'a vu à
Windsor pour ceux qui ont vu les images
c'est lui qui a retiré également les
trois joyaux du cercueil puisqu'il est
celui que allait toucher ça c'est quand
même une anecdote il a pas le droit de
les toucher mais si le coffret
qui font partie du trésor de la Couronne
et où sont-ils maintenant ils sont
retournés dans la tour de Londres on a
jewel house il faut savoir que ils sont
gardés sous trois vitres blagues sont
uniques au monde dit-on qui ont été
prévus spécialement pour garder les
joyaux de la couronne et ben ils
n'étaient plus sortis depuis 1950 on
peut pas avoir d'impact sur les vitres
de la pièce de 2 €
du couronnement
Carglass carglasserai pas Carglass
remplace
de la couronne de Flore et ben pour la
toute dernière petite anecdote en phrase
la végétation elle était coupée dans des
buissons et c'était déjà la végétation
qui était à son mariage en 1940 on a
démonté son bouquet de mariée en 1947 et
on a replanté la végétation la
végétation le plus en forme que Charles
vous savez ce qui va choqué un tout
petit peu
elle avait une canne les derniers
dernières semaines la reine et ils ont
brisé
lors de grand Chamberlin c'est la plus
haute autorité de la course
c'est un bâton en réalité le fait qu'il
casse ça veut donc dire que ça canne
ça veut dire que le pouvoir d'Elizabeth
II est brisé il est redépose les deux
morceaux de Cannes et à ce moment-là on
voit la dépouille ils disent ah c'est
incroyable dans la Hollywood moi aussi
j'ai pas aimé quand ils ont cassé tu
leur diras à tes potes
les roses tu leur diras ce que je peux
ok
merci en tout cas d'avoir été là
[Applaudissements]
plus une seule chambre des 6500 hôtels
que compte ne sont disponibles j'ai
regardé la chambre la plus minable se
négocier 500 €. et tous les tous les
touristes ils ont du manger ils ont du
boire
on aime le pouvoir de de de de l'argent
donc le mettre de l'argent même
lorsqu'il mord d'ailleurs on dit à Cyril
les rois ne meurent jamais
dont je ne me souviens absolument